if you thought watching movies with a
pair of flimsy 3d glasses was cool you
might be surprised and very interested
to see what the metaverse has to offer
virtual reality headsets can now allow
you access to gaming to movies even
concerts and as carter evans reports
more and more entertainment companies
are exploring how to use the metaverse
to blur the lines between reality and
your entertainment from tron in the 80s
to the matrix and ready player one once
science fiction the virtual world is
becoming a reality you can also grab one
of these swords filmmaker maureen fan is
one of the entertainment visionaries
upgrading traditional 2d movies okay now
i got my sword i think wait do i have it
to an entirely new experience there you
go it is crazy to think that you're
hundreds of miles away from me right now
yeah we're standing right next to each
other it's pretty cool she showed us
inside the virtual set her studio
created for the award-winning animated
interactive film baba yaga starring
glenn close and kate winslet
cheers
one day soon fan says you'll be able to
inhabit the universes of mainstream
movies like star wars in lord of the
rings are you talking about making
movies where we can come inside and look
around and interact absolutely i mean
how cool would it be to be able to be in
the universe that you love one that you
could never actually go to
except in your imagination but here we
can actually build it from sports events
to concerts gaming and beyond we could
soon be spending a lot of time in the
metaverse something mark zuckerberg
tried to bring mainstream last year it's
a virtual space where we meet play and
socialize and silicon valley insiders
say it's likely to upend the way we live
our lives we should think of the
metaverse as the next iteration of the
internet author matthew ball wrote a
book on the metaverse revolution and
says seven of the world's largest
companies are already investing
zuckerberg's meta spent 10 billion
dollars last year and microsoft acquired
world of warcraft creator activision
blizzard for 70 billion do you have any
idea how much the metaverse could be
worth most estimates for the overall
value of the metaverse suggest that it's
going to be roughly 6 to 10 trillion by
2032. trillion trillion that's right how
far away are we from the metaverse being
something that everyone's familiar with
in their everyday lives i think we're
almost there alan cook is creating a
studio to test ideas for the future of
entertainment in the metaverse he works
for deloitte a company traditionally
more familiar with spreadsheets than
interactive entertainment i think that
the way we consume content has been
kind of the same for the last 100 years
as we move forward it'll be in 3d
and that'll be the first time we truly
will be able to experience things in an
immersive way
keep her distracted i'll get us out of
here i promise by watching the movie and
interacting in it could you change the
outcome of the plot line yes at least
that is what we are doing we think
that's the power of being fully immersed
in something it's just crazy to think
that this is the future of going to the
movies yeah it's just so exciting to be
able to fully be inside the world and
feel like you're really there someone so
far fan studio has created eight
animated films each more complex and
interactive pushing the boundaries of
our imagination you can carry the
lantern and come with me i don't think
the metaverse ever replaces real life oh
look at that but i think it's just a
different way to experience it oh i
dropped it and it's a world that someone
else creates that you could have never
imagined that's when i think it's very
magical
it's just going to take some getting
used to for cbs morning's carter evans
los angeles oh keep practicing
tony why is there a break in the arms
they have you have sensors in your hands
but i guess they can't visualize the
arms and so that's also why it's so hard
to make the sensors talk to each other
to hand a flower yeah the other thing
that's the metaverse does not have going
for it is when you cut to that first
shot of you wearing the headset that's
you know everybody looks good everyone
looks goofy it does some things to your
hair you know you got the band here and
here
but the concept is very cool and it's
definitely coming and it's only going to
get better they're like yeah it's not
it's not coming the future is now it's
your year yeah you're making a really
good point yeah and for anybody that's
familiar with technology even video
games
this is what regular life will look like
you know those that might be detached
from the concept of living in this
virtual world it's kind of hard to grasp
but i feel like the future generations
this is going to be normal it will be no
big deal to them yeah